There's no shortage of gut-churning horror
films on Netflix...but a new offering has
audiences covering their mouths, clutching
their stomachs, and even getting sick.
It's safe to say The Perfection is unlike
any horror film you've ever seen before, on
Netflix, or anywhere else.
But before we get too deep into the nitty-gritty,
please note: Major spoilers ahead!
The Perfection stars Allison Williams and
Logan Browning as Charlotte and Lizzie, two
cello prodigies who study at the prestigious
music school Bachoff.
The film centers around Charlotte's return
to Bachoff after taking leave of absence to
look after her ailing mother.
She reconnects with her mentors and soon meets
the talented musician who replaced her when
she left.
That musician is Lizzie.
"I'm sorry, am I the luckiest man in the world?
I don't even drink and I feel drunk.
My two most perfect students together."
Based on the film's title and storyline, it's
easy to assume The Perfection will be a dark
tale of jealousy and one-upmanship...much
like Darren Aronofsky's 2010 psychological
thriller Black Swan, or the classic 1950 melodrama
All About Eve.
But then, after the first of many plot twists,
you might mistake The Perfection for a ghoulish
outbreak drama.
"What's happening?"
"Oh my god, your arm!"
But The Perfection is actually far more complex
than that, and the end result has a few far
more grotesque moments.
If Twitter can be believed, the film's occasional
grizzly moments, and insane ending, are making
viewers physically ill.
One Twitter user complained,
"i havent seen the whole thing but i watched
some scenes from the perfection on netflix
and it is literally making me feel sick."
Another viewer tweeted:
"the perfection on netflix is SICK…in a
bad way ugh my body can't move and i feel
like puking."
And yet another viewer totally agreed with
that assessment:
"Just got done eating while watching The Perfection
on Netflix and I think I’m going to puke."
But that's not to say it's a bad film by any
stretch of the imagination.
Plenty of people thought The Perfection was
a gripping and original horror movie.
One Twitter user breathlessly summed up her
feelings by writing:
"The film is sick, twisted, cunning, beautifully
made, creepy, evil, scary, funny, tragic all
at the same time.
What a psychological horror thriller!!"
While many viewers found it grueling to watch
The Perfection, it reportedly wasn't the easiest
film to make, either.
In one particularly gnarly scene, Lizzie has
a panic attack after vomiting maggots and
yellow bile all over a bus window.
Director Richard Shepard told Bloody Disgusting
that that scene proved to be rather challenging:
"It was tough to edit because Logan is yelling
and freaking out so much.
Just looking at takes was exhausting...But
I knew if we could get the sequence to work
it would be an amazing bit of movie-making."
Well, all that hard work certainly paid off.
Viewers are obviously totally freaked out
by The Perfection, which is Certified Fresh
on Rotten Tomatoes.
Many reviewers have praised the film, with
Katie Walsh of The Los Angeles Times claiming,
"The wild ride in store is both supremely
disturbing and unpredictable.
But rendered with such care, skill and sheer
glee, it's utterly divine."
The A.V.
Club's Katie Rife ultimately gave the film
a B minus, but also noted,
"The Perfection takes deep, fetishistic satisfaction
in pushing the envelope, then pushing it some
more, building in seductive fits and shocking
starts to an orgiastic frenzy of cinematic
excess."
The film definitely isn't for anyone with
a sensitive stomach...but if you're looking
for an original horror-thriller, go ahead
and check out The Perfection.
Just be sure to have a barf bag at the ready…and
don't say we didn't warn you.
"Help!
Help!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.